on va parler du sujet qui fait
énormément réagir aujourd'hui dans toute
la classe politique et sur toutes les
chaînes ils ont parlé que de ça alors
que le palais présidentiel accueillit la
conférence des Rabin européens Emmanuel
Macron a assisté à l'allumage de la
première bougie de hananuka fête juif
qui a démarré hier soir en présence du
Grand Rabin de France euh hananuka
d'ailleurs Joy au Hanuka à tous de
nombreuses voix se sont élevés pour
dénoncer une atteinte à la laïcité alors
comprenez-vous la polémique on va en
parler avec LOX signor qu'on aime
beaucoup porte-parole de renaissance qui
viendra nous dire ce qu'il en pense et
dites-nous vous si vous comprenez la
question c'est comprenez-vous la
polémique regardez la vidéol
[Musique]
em
d'abord avant avant avant de de revenir
là-dessus je voudrais dire que d'abord à
la base le palais présidentiel
accueillit la conférence des rabins
européens en fait c'est faut le rappeler
loï c'est ça en fait il remettait un
prix bonsoir au président de la
République pour sa lutte contre
l'antisémitisme c'est un prix qui a été
reçu par Angela Merkel par Manuel Vals
par le roi d'Espagne et c'était à cette
occasion qu'ils étaient reçus à l'Élysée
précision importante aussi il n'y avait
pas que des rabins il n'y avait pas que
des Juifs il y avait tous les cultes qui
étaient représentés hier soir à l'Élysée
et dernière précision je pense qu'on va
y venir dans les débats mais c'est pas
l'Élysée qui a organisé une cérémonie
religieuse c'est pas Emmanuel Macron qui
a dit on va faire ranuka à l'Élysée
c'est le grand Rabin de France qui lui a
fait j'en profite comme ça au moins
c'est clair le grand Rabin de France
Rahim Coria qui lui a demandé d'allumer
une bougie cette bougie ça s'appelle la
bougie du souvenir et elle vient
d'osvich c'est la bougie qui commémore
les morts de l'Holocauste ce n'est pas
le président de la République qui par la
suite a allumé cette bougie que Rahim
corcia a allumé lui-même pour célébrer
le premier jour de ranuka je comprends
que ça puisse étonner et surprendre
parce que le calendrier fait que nous
étions hier 2 mois après les massacres
le pogrom qui a eu lieu en Israël les
attaques terrifiantes du Hamas moi je
trouve qu'on est quand même dans un pays
extra ordinaire où on arrive à sindîner
24 heures des
commémorations du soutien inconditionnel
à la communauté juive 2 mois après ce
qui s'est passé et on a du mal parfois à
qualifier l'horreur de ce qui s'est
passé je parle de la classe politique là
je parle de la France insommise qui
depuis 2 mois se démarque par son
antisémitisme je trouve qu'on est
vraiment là dans la quintessence du
commentaire de la politique de la
polmique politicienne qui est finalement
assez veine par rapport aux enjus qui
sont les NES Jean-Luc Mélenchon non bah
Gill
euh non c'est une énorme faute politique
euh l'Élysée en plus c'est le symbole de
la France donc si je puis dire le temple
de la laïcité donc c'est terrible pour
moi je vais vous dire j'ai été meurtri
oh oui à hanoua non à laba quelques
semaines avant et ça c'est honteux c'est
impossible pour un président de la
République et d'ailleurs il rétropédale
même le cri fait contre vous rendez
compte M me je me permets t'interrompre
immédiatement je te tu toi parce qu'on
connais pas possible oui vous le
connaissez on a travaillé ensemblevec
Gill
moins longtemps que vous ah oui
comprends la laïcité n'empêche pas la
commémoration la célébration d'un fait
religieux c'est un symbole je je dis
simplement je rappelle ce qu'il y a dans
la Constitution tous les ans tous les
ans il y a une messe en présence de
sénateurs et de députés ça ne gêne
personne est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
supprime le Noël des enfants à l'Élysée
non mais là qui a lie chaque année
depuis de GA rien àir Alig pardon Noël
c'est une fête une fête religieuse Noël
et et dernièrement dernier point
là-dessus il n'y a pas d'interférence
entre ce qui s'est passé hier soir dans
la décision de l'État c'est ça le
principe de laïcité fondé en 1905 c'est
que l'église ou quel que soit le culte
ne doit pas interférer dans la décision
de l'État je ne pense pas que allumer la
bougie du souvenir en mémoire des
depportic soit une manière pour le
président de la République d'être guidé
dans sa décision dans son une action
politique encore une fois je peux
comprendre que ça puisse surprendre
établiss fa est-ce qu'on Faita Laï à
l'Élysée c'est pas pareil parce que hier
il n pas eu de célébration religieuse
par l'Élysée l'Élysée n'a pas organisé
de cérémonie religieuse et le président
de la République n'a pas lui-même été
complice coupable responsable d'une
cérémonie religieuse il a assisté à la
tradition juive à l'occasion d'une
remise de décoration qui justement on
devrait en être fier nous récompense
nous Français c'est dans la lutte que
l'on mène de manière acharnée contre
l'antisémitisme et ça je pense que
encore une fois on devrait en être plus
fier et condamner plus fermement les
dérapages antisémites quotidiens depuis
de mois de certains membres de la classe
politique plutôt que s'acharner sur le
président de la République qui a
simplement voulu témoigner de son
soutien inconditionnel à un peuple qui
souffre en France et en Israël depuis de
mois me fait rire moi c'est serait que
le par exemple le Président c'est vrait
casse casse le le un soir de Ramadan
é ça pe être
sympa il l'a déjà fait pas à l'élsée il
le fait chaque année moi je l'ai fait
avec avec lui au Maroc encore une fois
je peux comprendre que ça puisse
surprendre étonnner pas choqué parce que
quand on établit les faits je pense
qu'on est pas choqué si on s'arrête à ce
qui a été dit sur les réseaux sociaux
par la France insoumise immédiatement
hier dès qu'il y a eu une vidéo je peux
comprendre qu'on soit choqué j'ai le
sentiment dites-moi si je me trompe que
le le
président en fait il il a fait ça enfin
de ce que vous me dites c'était voilà
c'était dans le contexte il s'est dit
ben bien je vais le faire c'était pas
c'était pas un geste politique j'ai
l'impression non c'est absolument pas un
geste politique et on voit si on écoute
bien la vidéo Rahim corsel grand rabat
de France demander au président de la
République s'il a l'autorisation
d'allumer cette bougie imaginez un seul
instant que le président lui refuse
devant les grands rabins qui viennent de
lui remettre le Prix justement de celui
qui a lutté contre l'antisémitisme
imaginez un seul instant la polémique à
l'inverse alors est-ce qu'il dit non
est-ce qu' d'
mie pas av
av c'est très intéressant parce que là
qu'est-ce que vous faites est-ce que
vous dites non au grand Rabin vous dites
NON NON j'allume pas ta bougie ditesnous
on se met pas en condition pour qu'il
allume la
bougie dit non
fa Mo moi je trouve que pour moi c'est
vraiment à minima un fiasco de
communication min mauvaise idée d'abord
ça remet les Juifs au centre d'un débat
dont il se passe très bien en ce moment
parce que déjà on ne cesse de parler
d'eux pour des raisons qui sont
absolument
dramatiques et parce qu'il y a un
conflit au Proche-Orient et parce qu'il
y a une montée de l'antisémitisme et
donc en ce moment ils aimeraient bien
qu'on les lâche les Juifs d'ailleurs par
ailleurs ça renforce effectivement
d'ailleurs on l'a vu tout de suite c'est
la porte ouverte à ce deux poids de
mesure ah ben vous avez fait ça pour eux
et pourquoi pas pour nous ah ben la BAA
ah bah ceci à bas cela donc ce sentiment
que et et ça ouvre la porte à tous les
complotismes et à toutes les les
complotises antisémite c'est-à-dire il y
a une sorte de de complot juif qui qui
est sur les sur les élites et donc les
élites pourrait serait drivé par la
communauté juive la juiverie enfin
toutes ces choseslà qu'on peut entendre
et puis par ailleurs éabeth borne a
parlé de de de Macron du président
Macron pardonnez-moi qui fait ça pour
donner un signal à la communauté juive
et moi j' elle a simplement dit qu'elle
l' avait adressé son soutien Souen venir
à la marche contre l'antisémtisme
r rraper à une manifestation où il n pas
allé donc il y a rien qui va petit
secondes de petit secondes il y a
vraiment rien qui va aussi dans des
tweets puce qu'il y a des des gens qui
disent c'est quoi cette histoire de
Macron qui aura animé qui aurait allumé
Hanouna hier
[Rires]
soir et
pu Ren à boire et juste pour terminé et
et et d'ailleurs ils se sont engouffrés
dans la brèche la France insoumise vient
pour vous donner des leçons de laïcité
là on c'est
chich moi je suis estomaqué par tout ce
que j'entends je trouve ça absolument
incroyable parce que tout maintenant les
gens n'ont rien compris la laïcité la
laïité c'est pas la négation des
religions c'est permettre que chacun en
France puisse exercer librement son
culte donc où est le problème de vouloir
célébrer c'est une fête tu une
synagogueah voilà elle a
raison mais pas du tout mais je suis
après pour d'ailleurs le le le grand
Rabin de de Paris enfin le grand Rabin
le grand an de Paris était invité aussi
la cérém je suis pour que toutes les
fêtes religieuses soi représenté dans
une sorte de Concord c'est un moment
festif et même vous au nom de la lcité
vouslez supprimer tous les M festifs a
plus
que la lo 1905 séparation de l'Église et
de l'État la décision d'accord alors
parce qu'on allume une bougie a plus de
séparation la séparation de l'Église et
de l'État C parce que financer les
églises financer les prêtres et Cera on
arrêé
ig c'est religieux et alors c'est quoi
le problème c'est
gros comment mais pourquoi mais il faut
faire toutes les
religions grand F 36000 une fois que tu
as fait Noël
P Président c'est à expliquer pourquoi
il avait fait ça regarde c'était ce
matin cétait le vie est-ce que vous le
regrettez pas du tout mais le pays
parfois s'embrase hier je re
des rabins de l'Europe entière qui me
remettaient un prix décidé à plusieurs
mois reconnaissant la lutte de la France
contre l'antisémitisme et à l'issue de
cérémonie j'ai allumé c'est la tradition
de leur prise la bougie du souvenir
reven d'tz ensuite c'est le grand Ramin
qui a allumé les de boug je crois que
làdessus il faut savoir raison garder
tout ça a été fait d'ailleurs en
présence de tous les autres cultes qui
étaient invités qui étaient là et dans
un esprit qui est celui de la
on a une discussion avec Val c'est
trèsvaise la question il va pas non plus
ne pas répondre simplement c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant parce que
c'est plus fort évidment quand
présidentigion religion principe
religion c'est l'amour et vous cherchez
tous les prétex pour [__] sur laule
desigion je
disl quand le président la République le
dit ça plus de force que moi mais il
répète évidemment s'est passé et c'est
la bougie du souvenir la bougie du
souvenir ça n'a rien ça n'a rien de non
mais pardon ça n'a rien ça n'a rien
pardon ça n'a rien de religieux 1 il n'a
pas allumé la bougie de ranuka il a
allumé la bougie du souvenir 2 non c'est
pas des éléments de langage c'est la
réalité vous pouvez considérer que ce
sont des éléments de langage c'est ça la
réalité 2 de je vous dis une chose c'est
pas l'Élysée qui a décidé de mettre en
place cette bougie c'est le grand Rabin
de France qui a cru bien faire et moi je
vis vous dire je le soutiens je le
soutiens pourquoi parce que de mois
après ce qui s'est passé je pense qu'on
a le droit de à un moment donné montrer
un soutien renforcé à la communauté
juive de France et d'Israël pardon j'ai
l'impression que aujourd'hui on ne le
dit pas suffisamment et qu'on a tendance
à oublier que de mois il y a 1200 morts
se sont fait assiner dans dans
considraation terrible troisièmement le
président de la République il garant de
l'unité et j'entendais sur la marche et
c'est exactement ce que l'on redoutait
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ce que l'on
craignait qu'il y ait des esprits
chagrins des instrumentalisateurs
professionnels
nous aurait dit le président va à la
marche contre l'antisémitisme donc le
président soutient la politique de
benamin netah c'est exactement les
raisons qu'on a tenté d'exliquer je
crois que j'étais venu sur ce plateau
pour le faire qui nous sont aujourd'hui
reprochés à l'inverse et donc il faut
trouver et je vous en conjure un
semblant d'unité dans ce
pays le CRIF a le droit d'être contre le
parce que si le CRIF à 8h30 du matin
chez jean-jacqu Bourdin se calque sur le
récit des insoumis et bien il n'a pas
forcément tous les éléments en tête et
moi je crains que Monsieur Harfi ce
matin n'it pas tous les éléments en tête
parce que qui a tweeté très rapidement
qui s'est engouffré immédiatement dans
la brèche Monsieur Manuel bonpard le
patron fantoche de cette organisation
mélanchoniste et donc il va oui pardon
j'ai le ver mais il n'y a que trois
adhérents à la France insommise donc
pour moi c'est une organisation fantoche
ils sont aujourd'hui dans un délit à
chaque fois ils sont dans un procès
d'intention pardon au sujet d'Emmanuel
Macron ils serait d'un côté ou d'un
autre moi je ne le crois pas il est le
garant de
l'unité parce ils
instrumentalisent Berard ils nont pas
les éléments Bernard mon ce que je
voulais dire c'est que d'abord je
voulais rappeler qu'il y avait tous les
les représentants de tous les cultes qui
étaient là ça c'était important ouais
mais cétait là important ça veut dire
que c'était vraiment
que et d'autant plus je vous rappelle
aussi que Monsieur shirac l'avait déjà
fait ça n'avait pas posé de problème qui
a une chapelle à l'élyisée aussi cétait
bureau c'est devenu le bureau c'était
gérles de Gaul qui avait fait ça on
pouvait se permettre peut-être à une
certaine époque alors peut-être que
l'époque est plus difficile et que tout
est matière à controverse maintenant
comme vous l'avez souligné loï
effectivement c'estim kchia qui est le
grand Rabin de France qui demande au
Président est-ce que je peux le faire
vous voyez dire non il vient de recevoir
ce ce grand prix qui récompense son sa
lutte contre l'antisimitisme et la
sauvegarde vous êtes choqué ou pas oui
parce maintenant oui non je comprends la
polémique non je sais pas on comprend
pas
Bernard quand vous voulez pas comprendre
faites les cons je vous dis je comprends
la polémique mais je vous explique tu su
ou tu sues
pas toujours Élég
Franch la même
vulgarité côté je m'en
les
tonable qu tu jouer con c'est dramatique
ah remet ton truc et oui ou non j'ai dit
oui je comprends la polémique mais on
l'explique la polémique quand on la
comprend pas comme toi avec tes copains
de LFI c'est pas mes copains mais gros
de mélanchant toute ta bande de ringar
tu sais plus quoi
dire soit courageux je l'ai mis depuis
le début abruti il y voit même plus à
son âge voilà elle est sympa cette
émission ambiance vraiment vraiment
vraiment Jadine non mais vous êtes un
pompier courageux mais malgré tout je
come tous les pompiers ouis mais je
trouve que malgré tout bah la polémique
est totalement légitime et je trouve que
c'est vraiment une faute politique mais
vraiment majeure en fait ils ont fait
quoi en fait les Français de confession
juif pour mériter ça depuis le 7 octobre
que ce soit les ambiguïtés et les
tergiversations de la France insoumise
et maintenant Macron ambigué de la
France insouise bah oui enfin rien
d'ambigu dire plus fa pas dire plus bien
bien sûr même des féministes même les
féministes qui ont été immondes aussi en
fait tout le monde est immonde et j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait on prend les les
Français juifs comme une sorte de
variable ajustable pour les petit truc
politique des uns et des autres et
pardonnez-moi je trouve que alors en
plus ce que vous dites c'est que le
grand Rabin de France aurait donné donc
c cette bougie un peu donc de force à
Monsieur
Macron non mais ça veut dire que non
mais ça veut dire c'est pire ça veut
dire que quelque part en fait on
instrument on va instrumentaliser n
antis tout le monde parle les gars vous
parlez trop là ceux qui on parler
làdessus et Pascal je trouve que que la
religion prend de plus en plus de place
dans la société prend trop de place je
vrais Rapp parce rappelle jamais que la
majorité plus de 50 % des Français sont
hatâtés agnostiqu et en fait on on a
l'impression que tous les débats sont
monopolisé par les religions et on n
peut plus donc en fait il y a un moment
où ce qu'on attend notre de notre
gouvernement ce qu'on attend de notre
Président c'est autre chose c'est que il
y a une prise de hauteur et pas voilà
clairement moi quand je vois ça je me
dis c'est finalement une une une
tentative de rattrapage et on va on va
créer des polémiques et on sait très
bien que c'était c'était prévisible
qu'on allait avoir ce genre de débat et
on est on becoup à mettre oui on n pas
tousfi vous voyez ce que je veux dire je
vous accuse
pasélement ce que je dis simplement
c'est que j'essaie d'expliquer les faits
tels qu'ils sont et moi je vous dis je
comprends qu'on puisse être étonné qu'on
puisse être surpris mais à partir du
moment où on a les faits tel que je les
ai exposé que le président les a exposé
lui-même je peux attendreux attend de
chacuxend de chacun un peu de bon sens
j'utilise pas
l'argument
Pr e
terminercout signor je pense que c'est
une erreur de communication majeure ces
images là ne sont pas expliqués sont
arrivés effectivement sur les réseaux on
voit et on a le sentiment qu'Emmanuel
Macron est en train de se racheter le
fait de ne pas être allé à cette
manifestation contre l'antisémitisme et
qui se rachète de de cette façon et on a
le sentiment que ça sonne tout fa vous
avez le droit d'avoir le sentiment mais
je ve
dire pr le prix reçu par Emmanuel Macron
hier vous connaissez l'agend président
tout con tout le monde mais il est
décidé ce prix il y a des mois et on
coche la date on coche la date du 7
décem
rage pas rattrapage ça aura pu
intervenir avant la marche Mara
intervenir avant la remise du prix je TR
moi je trouve ça inapproprié parce que
par exemple il a énormément de musulmans
qui souffrent aussi il y a pas il fait
pas de coutumes religieuse il participe
pas à des coutumes religieuses à
l'Élysée donc je trouve ça inapproprié
et en tant que at faire ça àélysée je
trouve que et pareil je trouve que il
voulait se rattraper par parce qu'il est
pas il il a pas participé à la marche tu
répètes tu encore mieux allez on va voir
ce qu'on pense les téléspectateurs tiens
prenez-vous la polémique oui à 70 % non
30 c'est plus mitigé que ce qui se passe
sur le c'est mon meilleur score depuis
que
[Rires]
jefendu dans un instant les chéis avec
du lourd on aura Yan Mo qui viendra nous
voir concernant le enquête le complément
d'enquête de Gérard pardieu hier avec on
va reviendra dessus et puis Jade et Joy
vous avez vu elles sont très énervées
hein elle ne pourra jamais pardonner à
David etur euh ça c'est c'est un truc de
sont vénèes es sont vénèes après tout le
monde là c'est des chocs Noris là fou à
tout de
suite